this is dave klein reading for steven
petit
cuphead the delicious last course was
worth the wait the level of detail and
display in the dlc's handful of boss
fights is simply mind-boggling more than
just visually impressive though the new
boss fights are more exciting dynamic
and mechanically diverse coupled with a
creative new playable character miss
chalice and multiple interesting new
weapon slash charms the delicious last
course is a triumph that both expands on
the base game in clever ways while also
improving the original campaign itself
[Music]
miss chalice is a game changer in the
delicious last course so it's not too
surprising that the dlc story is
centered around her the legendary
chalice a ghost who granted players
super arts abilities in the main
campaign wants to come back to life to
do that miss chalice cuphead and mugman
must collect ingredients for the wonder
tart from the bosses scattered across
inkwell aisle 4. in the meantime there's
a temporary fix for her not being a live
problem the astral cookie a new charm
that can be equipped to play as miss
chalice and playing as miss chalice is a
fairly significant departure especially
for someone like me who has played the
original campaign so many times while
the two brothers are functionally the
same fighter miss chalice meaningfully
changes how it feels to go up against
the assortment of larger than life
bosses the astral cookie charm gives
miss chalice three unique abilities
double jump dash parry and invincible
roll she also gets an extra hit point
considering that cuphead is largely play
with three buttons jump shoot and dash
altering how any of these operate can
shake things up her moveset is extremely
versatile and it fundamentally changes
the way you can approach boss fights the
dash parry combined with the double jump
allows you to move in ways that simply
weren't possible as cuphead or mugman
you can jump once dash into a projectile
and then jump again in a different
direction projectiles that were
previously out of reach are now
reachable so miss chalice winds up
feeling like a character who can and
should be on the move almost constantly
you can cover more ground with her moves
and this even leads to a whole new way
of approaching the original campaign's
collection of bosses
meanwhile the invincible role introduces
an entirely new mechanic you have to
crouch and then dash to execute the
nifty maneuver functionally it's similar
to the smoke bomb charm except you have
to be on the ground to perform it the
dodge roll has the biggest learning
curve since you have to press down and
dash but it gives you an incredibly
useful method for dodging attacks that
critically doesn't require you to expose
yourself to airborne projectiles
it's clear that the six bosses that
inhabit inkwell aisle four were designed
with miss chalice's suite of abilities
in mind the cadence of projectiles and
locations of them make them a natural
fit for double jumps dash parries and
dodge rolls each boss is more elaborate
than the last while the cadence of the
multi-phase battles will feel familiar
to cuphead veterans the level of detail
compared to the main campaign's bosses
is truly astounding with more frames of
animation dynamic backdrops and an
increased amount of visual flourishes to
the bosses themselves the delicious last
course takes the hallmark feature of the
cuphead experience to the next level
take glomstone the giant the first dlc
boss for example he's a perfect
demonstration of how the dlc does more
with his characters to bring them to
life the chaotic first phase includes
projectile vomit gnomes with hammers
flocks of geese and even a bear to
contend with it's a humorous and
creative start that only gets better
during the second phase which features a
delightful callback to foes from the
main campaign and the surprises keep
coming as the third phase changes the
stage all together all three phases come
together to create a varied fight that
forced me to use different techniques
and swap between weapons while
multi-environment fights with that much
variation aren't entirely new in cuphead
the fight with glomstone is comparable
to the final showdowns with king dice
and the devil the most mechanically
interesting bosses in the original
what's most impressive is that every
boss in the dlc has a final boss feel to
it from a design perspective doggone
dogfight has the coolest stage across
the entire cuphead experience you're
pitted against the howling aces a team
of dogs specializing in aerial
spectacles you have to participate in
the stunts too as you're confined to
walking across the top of a small
airplane that's zipping through the air
since you only have a little platform to
work with definitely time jumps and
dodges are key when a giant flying
mechanical dog passed by me in the sky i
sensed the final phase was going to be
tricky i wasn't prepared for the final
stunt and even after i knew it was
coming it still frequently tripped me up
that's the other thing about the dlc
bosses their unique variations and wide
array of attacks forced you to stay
nimble even during phase transitions
which were often moments of reprieve in
the base game the moonshine mob has a
level of deception not present in any
other boss fight as the final phase
really is all about forcing you to make
ill-advised decisions the fight also
adds some fresh verticality into the mix
allowing you to attack from both above
and below the boss there's only one
actual aerial boss on the bunch a cow
named esther winchester who hides out in
a saloon esther rivals dr khal's robot
in terms of complexity for this type of
cuphead boss as it has a couple of the
most chaotic sequences throughout the
entire game the fight also gives you an
opportunity to try miss chalice's
slightly different play mechanics her
default plane attack is a spreadshot and
her bomb attack is faster but not as
precise as cupheads in practice neither
of these moves really gives miss chalice
an advantage against esther mainly
because hitboxes and cuphead aren't
always very big in the aerial fights
unsurprisingly it's not just the visuals
that make the delicious last course a
beautiful homage to cartoons of the
1930s and early 1940s just like the rest
of the game the dlc has a catchy
orchestrated soundtrack with a mixture
of strings and horn instruments the
jazzy toons have a big band vibe to them
and they wonderfully complement the
on-screen action try to play cuphead on
mute and see how much is lost without
the accompanying music crackling effects
and rhythmic sounds made by the weapons
and other objects cuphead wouldn't be
cuphead while the new bosses certainly
feel aligned to miss chalice's moves you
can square off against them as cuphead
or mugman for a whole new challenge that
asks you to rethink your approach to
certain attacks
figuring out how to avoid obstacles that
felt like a natural fit for miss jealous
was like solving a clever riddle the new
heart ring charm certainly helps it has
one point on your first third and sixth
parries with the caveat that parrying
won't fill up your super meter for
players who pride themselves on parrying
every object in sight you're rewarded
for your diligence and given more leeway
from some of the trickier projectiles to
dodge his cuphead a trio of new weapons
can be used by any character and they
are highly versatile crackshot will be
the most useful for newcomers as it
shoots straight at first before breaking
into homing projectiles think of it as a
better version of the chaser converge
has two different fire patterns a full
screen spreadshot and a concentrated
burst of electricity the latter of which
can only be accessed by holding the lock
button to stop you from moving left or
right the twist up is quite different
from other weapons in the game thanks to
little tornadoes that move in an upward
arcing path though veteran players
likely already have their go-to weapons
the three new options may make you
rethink your strategy unlike some of the
original weapons each of these are
useful for almost any boss in the game
new weapons and charms are once again
purchased from the shop but there aren't
any dlc run and gun levels to collect
coins in instead studio mdhr introduced
a series of fights called the king's
leap located in a castle in the sky the
king's leap's five stages are perry-only
fights against chest themed foes you
start against a series of fast-moving
pawns before moving on to larger foes
like a sword-wielding knight a bouncing
bishop and an axe grinding knight these
wind up feeling like platforming levels
each with their own unique requirements
for damaging a boss with the power of
your parry alone these stages are almost
as entertaining as the regular bosses
which makes them a worthy substitute for
the somewhat rote run and gun levels
you may be wondering just how
challenging is the dlc all the bosses
are at least as challenging as equal
aisle 3 and inkwell hell fights some
sections of fights are more trying than
any aspect of the base game while this
chalice does make things slightly easier
overall each boss is still a test of
skill that will likely trip up seasoned
players those who fell off of the base
game due to getting stuck may have a
path forward with miss chalice since you
can unlock her early in the game and go
through most of the main adventure as
her the challenge of cuphead is part of
his identity and those who appreciated
that balance of beauty and frustration
will find that the dlc embraces that
spirit all of that said because the
delicious last course makes an already
visually striking game even more
stunning it would have been nice to see
some optional accessibility and
difficulty features to open up the game
to more players nevertheless cuphead the
delicious last course was worth the long
wait miss chalice gives players a brand
new way to approach each boss and each
of the new boss fights is an imaginative
triumph from both a visual and gameplay
perspective the new perry focused fights
as a twist of the cuphead platforming
formula that feels right at home while
offering something new to the experience
even the already great main campaign has
improved thanks to miss chalice and a
trio of new weapons that shake things up
for cuphead and mugman cup had the
delicious last course as more than a
cherry on top it changes the recipe to
create a game that's more scrumptious
than before
[Music]
you